Emmanuel Macron à l'étranger mais
rattrapé par l'actualité sociale
française de chef de l'État prononcer un
discours sur l'Europe au premier jour de
sa visite au Pays-Bas quand des
manifestants ont tenté de l'interrompre
les ont dérouler banderole avec
l'inscription président de la violence
et de l'hypocrisie
[Musique]
I can I mais l'actualité c'est aussi
évidemment cette information
[Applaudissements]
oui je peux répondre à cette question si
vous si vous me laissez le temps vous
l'avez montrant en début d'émission il
est arrivé à peu près la même chose à
Emmanuel Macron aujourd'hui à la Huet à
la haie les militants ont ensuite été
sortis de la salle comme on le voit sur
ces images
si ces exacts
Yannick s'est onomatopée désigne une
rumeur destinée à créer l'événement dans
les médias ou sur Internet
[Musique]
oui bien sûr
c'est une onomatopée anglaise à la base
qui veut dire bourdonnement sur les BD
anglaises on peut voir une mouche qui
passe et le bruit c'est le voilà le
Buzzle
à Tarantino ça m'a fait penser à du Pulp
Fiction j'ai vrai ou j'ai pas vrai
là-dedans vous avez senti ça quand vous
avez ouais mais c'est vrai que c'est un
vrai côté Pulp Fiction j'imagine que
justement
pas plus que ça vous avez pas vu de
Tarantino c'est vrai ça je vois qui est
Tarantino mais je sais pas bien
de la jeune Marie-Luce c'est parce qu'il
a souffert aussi dans le passé de ne pas
être celui que la société voudrait qu'il
soit il est homosexuel mais à des années
lumières de la caricature
c'est une surprise dans le film et puis
et oui donc j'avais dit je voulais
cacher cette cet élément surprise c'est
comme si vous disiez là le nom de
l'assassin à la fin avant que le film
soit sorti le R mais champ cardinal dans
les trois mousquetaires de Dumas
avant de vous le dire quand je dois vous
dire à quel point j'aime votre invité
voilà
[Rires]
super alors aujourd'hui sachez que nous
allons recevoir Manon manon est né avec
deux utérus bon
je savais que ça allait jeter un pavé
dans la mort
il a fallu marcher de façon plus virile
vous étiez désemparé il a fallu que
Victoria Bedos vous fasse une
démonstration
et Victoria m'a indiqué le chemin de la
virilité c'est à dire globalement marché
les gens ouverts pour laisser de la
place aux tasty
c'est quand même ça l'idée
qu'on est quand même très des impôts moi
je paye mes impôts en France donc ça
part vite mais oui non franchement super
non donc ça va toi moi honnête
mais ceci dit je suis en train de faire
une très mauvaise année
j'ai fait une très belle année passée et
cette année ici je suis d'une
fainéantise avec un an et demi après le
décès de Bernard Tapie son épouse
Dominique est ruiné l'homme d'affaires a
laissé une dette de 660 millions d'euros
dans l'affaire du Crédit Lyonnais elle
en a déjà remboursé près de 150 millions
grâce à la vente d'un hôtel particulier
parisien et d'une villa à Saint-Tropez
mais la dette se creuse un peu plus à
cause des taux d'intérêt 90 000 euros en
plus chaque jour Dominique Tapie raconte
vivre aujourd'hui avec le strict minimum
environ 800 euros par mois le niveau de
revenu minimum pour mener une vie
décente en France en 2023 ce serait
1630 euros net par mois pour une
personne célibataire cette somme elle
monte à 3744 euros net pour un couple
avec deux enfants la décence évoquée par
cette économiste est à distinguer qu'on
s'entende bien de la subsistance
[Applaudissements]
aux yeux du chercheur vivre décemment
c'est être capable de subvenir à ses
besoins l'alimentation le logement etc
mais aussi pouvoir subvenir à ce qu'est
il considère comme étant des
incontournables de la vie en société que
sont par exemple les invitations entre
amis pouvoir inviter sa famille des amis
chez soi les sorties culturelles pouvoir
aller au cinéma ou théâtre de temps en
temps pouvoir
les vacances pouvoir partir au moins une
fois par an une jeune écossaise tombée
enceinte après une aventure d'une nuit à
Tenerife et en Espagne a lancé un appel
un peu particulier sur le réseau social
Tik Tok à quelques jours de
l'accouchement elle recherche activement
le père de son futur enfant qui serait
lui aussi écossais
de nombreux internautes cherchent à
découvrir l'identité du géniteur
d'autres préfèrent se moquer en saluant
la fertilité du jeune homme on s'amuse
bien sans maman
oui ou non
[Musique]
allez l'image du jour pour terminer
c'est selon toute vraisemblance le
visage du prochain dalaï-lama voilà vous
savez tout moi je vous donne rendez-vous
jeudi car je suis là Yann on ne fera
plus rien
problème à le dire moi tu sais je suis
comme Ibrahimovic je dis tout genre rien
à [__] dans 10 ans ou dans 20 ans
frère crois-moi on se rappellera ni tu à
l'animateur de quotidien ni de
l'animateur de c'est à VOUS frère on se
reparlera de TPMP on se rappellera de
vous je vous le dis on se rappellera pas
de qui est granimé c'est à vous ou qui
animait quotidien on dira c'était le
gars je sais pas avec les Stan Smith on
s'en bat les gars c'est une vente aux
enchères tout à fait exceptionnelles
pour terminer qui se tient aujourd'hui
chez sudbyes à New York cette vente
c'est celle d'une paire de basket portée
par le légendaire Michael Jordan le
joueur de basket lors d'un grand match
de NBA en 1998 alors pour la petite
histoire c'est du 47 et demi et
tenez-vous bien vous les voyez ces
baskets et bien ils sont estimés entre
deux et près de 4 millions d'euros 4
millions d'euros pour cette paire de
baskets ça fait réfléchir